the unmasking of Mike Flynn in the last
days of the Obama administration is the
most egregious political scandal of our
lifetimes and we've just learned it goes
all the way up to Joe Biden maybe even
higher
meanwhile the new masking order in LA
caps off the most arbitrary political
power graph of our lifetimes
luckily President Trump is starting to
break with his expert dr. dictators then
another rough interview for Joe Biden a
big Republican win in California and
finally the mail bag all that more I'm
Michael Knowles and this is the Michael
Nolt show
[Music]
facemasks are now required in this city
of Los Angeles every time you leave your
home not when you go into a store not
when you go to the supermarket any time
you leave your home you could be going
on a hike in the middle of nowhere
you're two miles from anybody or more
you still have to wear your mask I am
obviously going to ignore that order and
I recommend that all of you do as well
if you happen to be in Los Angeles or
anywhere else one of these draconian
rules is in place but that's not the end
to the crazy arbitrary power grabs we'll
get to masking we'll get to the
unmasking because this Obama gate thing
is real I usually play it pretty safe
when it comes to these scandals you know
I usually tamp down expectations this
one's pretty big it goes up pretty high
a question for you I'd love to hear your
thoughts in the comment section which if
any senior Obama officials are gonna
face consequences because of this
clapper Brennan Biden higher up who
knows who knows I'd love to hear your
thoughts before we get into all of that
I got to thank our friends over it keeps
you know even during this panic even
during this lockdown got to take care of
your hair because then you will emerge
still looking great okay and you used to
have to go to the doctor's office for
your hair loss prescription now thanks
to keeps you can visit a doctor online
and get hair loss medication delivered
right to your home keeps makes it very
easy and they deliver your medication
every three months you can say goodbye
to pharmacy checkout lines and awkward
doctor visits prevention is the key here
okay
keeps treatments can keep up - can take
up to four to six months or more to see
results so it's important to act fast
the sooner you start using keeps the
more hair you'll save you know I'm not
exactly an Adonis necessarily an Olympic
athlete or anything but I've always had
good hair and I always help me with the
ladies keep says more 5-star reviews
than any of its competitors nearly a
hundred thousand men trust keeps for
their hair loss prevention if you're
ready to take action and prevent hair
loss go to keeps calm slash Knowles
kayano wles to receive your first month
of treatment for free my gift to you K
EEP s.com
slash Knowles
so I'm not going to comply with this
mask order in Los Angeles this is
arbitrary it has no bearing on reality
I'm just not going to do it okay I'm
there's a very famous short story a lot
of kids read it in school it's called
Bartleby the Scrivener by Herman
Melville the guy wrote Moby Dick and in
it you know there's this guy Bartleby
and Bartleby is working at this office
and whenever he's told to do something
he just says I would prefer not to he
just you can say that to your boss hey
go go write up this thing go do this
thing I would prefer not to that's how I
feel about this order we got another we
got another piece of news from Los
Angeles yesterday remember we covered
these arbitrary public health rulings so
they've told us now they've heard us
they say the beaches are open but for
active use only no passive use on the
beach face coverings are required when
you're sitting on the beach so you see
you're gonna get a very awkward tan line
because this bottom part of your face is
gonna be very pale and the upper part is
going to be tan you must maintain six
feet of distance from others if it's
five feet 11 inches you will get
coronavirus but six feet and 1 inch
should be good you are permitted on the
beach to swim surf body board run and
walk maybe not jogging jogging might be
up in the air but you are not permitted
it is prohibited for you to sit or
sunbathe or play volleyball or picnic
you can't picnic or bike you can run but
you can't bike you can surf but you
can't bike you can walk but you can't
sit and you can't sunbathe even though
some preliminary evidence shows that
vitamin D is a very good way to fight
off coronavirus but I don't know they
don't want you to get too much Sun too
much vitamin D it's just it's absurd
obviously I feel like Nancy Pelosi at
the State of the Union it's it's
arbitrary is the problem and arbitrary
power grabs are not what we're about in
this country we like the rules to be
clear we have a country that is based on
a constitution that builds up instead
builds up institutions that then pass
laws for us and govern us not the whims
of some two-bit tin-pot dictator x' how
long is this gonna go on for we were
told initially three months by la
officials then they decided to walk that
back because there was an uproar but
they didn't totally walk it back now
even if they're gonna start reopening
certain things the mayor of La is saying
that the city is not going to reopen
until there's a cure which may never
come I think we have to all recognize
that we're not moving beyond cope at 19
we're learning to live with it it's
important not to overreact but it's
important to take this serious because
it is as dangerous today as it was the
first day that it arrived in our cities
in our country so quite frankly there's
no so-called open state or open country
that doesn't continue to have health
orders telling us to cover our faces
physically distance and to tell people
that your safest working from and
staying at home at the same time we take
steps forward for instance this past
weekend we opened up our trails we have
retail for curbside pickup we'll see
that expanded and even some active
recreation on our beaches this coming
weekend those are important and we've
never been fully closed we'll never be
completely open until we have a cure but
I do believe that we can take steps but
monitor those numbers listen to the
scientists and the medical professionals
and make the tough calls even when
there's criticism until we have a cure
we'll never go back to normal we're
gonna have to be safer at home and until
we have a cure we have to wear masks
cover our faces cover the expressive
part of our bodies shut ourselves up
until there's a cure can't sit on the
beach in Southern California until
there's a cure what makes this guy think
there's going to be a cure do we have a
cure for AIDS do we have a cure for Zika
do we have a cure for Ebola do we have a
cure for the common cold do we have a
cure for any any of these viruses
diseases know people who put their faith
in science we did all show yesterday
about the false god science
people who put their faith in modern
medical natural science are going to be
disappointed we just pretend that okay
well yes it takes 14 months and 4 days
to develop a vaccine to fight off a
novel virus and and epidemic we don't
know maybe we'll get a vaccine maybe we
won't and by the way if we do get a
vaccine how many people do you think
want to be in the first test group on
that vaccine
something tells me about zero so how are
you actually gonna get people to take it
you're gonna you're gonna force them to
take it you're gonna do coerced
injections I don't know a way the
government government power grabs have
been going possibly just saying this is
going to take a long time and we have to
return to normal and I'm sick of these
two-bit tin pot banana republic
dictators like Eric Garcetti flexing
their muscles saying you can yeah you
can ride a bike but you can't you can't
jog you can and you can't sunbathe but
you can you can you know roll around in
the sand and you can hop on one foot
well singing the national anthem in the
top hat but you're not allowed to wear a
fedora I mean just ridiculous senseless
kind of rulings I frankly I think I
don't think I'm exaggerating I think I'm
going to easy on him
we are not ruled by these guys we're and
these guys are exporting their power to
tenth to scientific lab code dictators
fortunately though well you hear foul
chu saying we have to follow the science
all he'll the medical science there's
some evidence that trump is beginning to
break with some of our lab coat
dictators President Trump you know was
asked about doctor foul Chi The Exalted
doctor foul Chi doctor fat she has been
similarly discouraging of reopening and
Trump is finally breaking with him he
said he disagrees with pouchy on when we
can open the schools so Anthony is a
good person very good person I've
disagreed with him
when I closed the border to China he
disagreed with that and then ultimately
he agreed he said I saved hundreds of
thousands of lives which is what
happened
everybody disagreed when I did that I
think that we have to open our schools
young people are very little affected by
this we have to get the schools open we
have to get our country open we have to
open our country now we want to do it
safely but we also want to do it as
quickly as possible we can't keep going
on like this I mean you're gonna have
you're having bedlam already in the
streets you can't you can't do this we
have to get it open I totally disagree
with him on schools so I think Trump is
right here I there's a caveat to that
but I think Trump is right Anthony foul
he might be a good person might be a
nice guy
I'm sick of Fuji no more foul gee okay I
don't pass a constitutional amendment
that says that doctor foul Qi rules me
otherwise enough pouchy okay yes we need
schools to reopen we can't just pause
our lives indefinitely like Eric R said
he wants us to the one caveat I say to
this is the longer that the schools
remain closed the better our chances of
breaking this sort of state education
monopoly that they have the kind of
craziness that is taught in schools I
mean we did a story on this show a few
months ago about a preschool in Brooklyn
that's teaching little three and
four-year-olds that boys or girls and
girls or boys and you can pick your own
gender that's not great stuff so if we
could crack that a little bit if we
could show people that maybe they don't
need to spend a quarter of a million
dollars to go to some college where they
won't learn anything won't get any
practical training either and we'll end
up in debt for the rest of their lives
if we could do that that might not be
the worst effect of this lockdown
actually that might be a silver lining
in the storm cloud but broadly speaking
we have to reopen society there's no
amount of money we can spend there is no
policy we can write up and craft and
pass that will make up for everybody
sitting at home for six months or eight
months or ten months or if the mayor of
LA is to be believed forever until we
get a cure the left is furious the
president
is disagreeing with pouchy particularly
those Cuomo brothers Fredo Cuomo who has
a CNN show and Anthony Cuomo the Anthony
Cuomo Andrew Cuomo the governor of New
York here or the Cuomo's outrage at
questioning our benevolent dr. dictator
I want to show you a clip of the
president today talking about Tony Fauci
because it is a demonstration of how
feelings are overwhelming fact in this
situation literally by intentional
assault the president is playing to
people's feelings we got to reopen you
got to be back in school you're not
really open it's been too long
and that's why states are reopening gov
because it's not about the facts that
are reopening them you are gonna have to
follow that same path if the people
demand it
yeah Trump is manipulating people's
feelings unlike Chris Cuomo who would
never think of doing that even though he
said that anyone who thinks we should
ever reopen society is basically killing
grandma and is responsible for tens of
thousands of deaths what a joke what a
joke this guy is this dichotomy here by
the way between fact and feeling on this
issue is a complete false one on the one
hand the the left which has been pushing
the alarmism does not have the facts on
their side they said early on that big
study the Imperial College study that we
based all of our policies on said 2.4
million Americans dead right that wasn't
true that was way way off so many of the
other models from the so-called
scientists way way off so they don't
have facts on their side the
conservatives who said what's what's
Sweden doing over there maybe we should
actually try to develop a sort of herd
immunity increasingly it seems pretty
clear that they had the facts on their
side there's a very good article in
foreign policy in the magazine that just
came out yesterday
on how we're all gonna end up like
Sweden anyway because of course we are
if we're not going to get a vaccine
anytime soon and the hospital systems
are not being overwhelmed and the virus
continues to spread then the only option
is for the virus to spread that it's not
necessarily a wonderful thing but that's
just where we are so they don't have the
facts on their side but similarly it
when we come to manipulating feeling the
left has been doing this from the very
beginning and even more important than
that
tics involves some feeling okay that's
why we elect people that's why we have a
representative democracy is so that the
government can take the pulse on how
we're all feeling if if we were just
gonna have a fact but I don't even
really believe in this distinction here
between the facts and values and things
like that but if we were just gonna have
a purely cold sterile fact-based
politics then we wouldn't have elections
why would you have elections you would
just appoint the best experts and they
would run the country but you would you
adjust a point you would basically
construct robots just to run the country
and it all be run on facts that would
have no care about people's feelings but
we don't do that because our
representative democracy has more than
just these technocratic robot overlords
we express our feelings we express our
desires we express our preferences we
express the amount of risk that we're
willing to endure to live to not be held
prisoner in our own homes to be able to
express ourselves and not have a
freaking mask covering our face all the
time in perpetuity on the beach we
express those preferences and those
desires that's what politics is it
involves a fair bit of feeling Cuomo
knows that both Cuomo's know that
because they're demagogues themselves
but they they want to claim fact you
know this is what they do with science
remember the word science comes from the
Latin word sheer a for all of human
knowledge and then these very narrow
materialists they they claim all of
knowledge for themselves now there's
some wisdom in other places too there's
some wisdom in the American people and
there's a lot of evidence that they're
beginning to turn on these draconian
policies
well there's wisdom in the American
people let's not forget there's a lot of
foolishness and corruption in the
government this is the biggest story the
biggest political scandal of our
lifetimes Obama gate Obama gate I know
you people think it's being hyped
they're being told it's a conspiracy
it's it is a conspiracy it's not a
conspiracy theory it's a conspiracy fact
we now know what happened and this is
some brutal brutal stuff we'll get to it
in one second first though I've got to
thank our friends the Benham brothers so
coronavirus obviously having a big
impact on small businesses never more
important to manage your business
workforce and workflow really well
systems are crucial right now that
Benham brothers are fabulous at this
these guys have over a dozen businesses
they got a real estate empire that spans
over thirty five states just a few weeks
ago the Benham brothers launched a new
podcast called expert ownership in their
new podcast the Benham brothers
interview leaders from all walks of life
to help you navigate your business
through these challenging times you'll
hear from leaders like Senator Ted Cruz
I know that guy
I've heard of him al Robertson from duck
dynasty many more I really like them
they're super cool guys they're they're
really great at presenting this
information as well and they got the
experience to back it up go check out
their new podcast expert ownership and
be sure to subscribe on Apple podcasts
or wherever you listen we'll drop a link
to their podcast in our show description
that is expert ownership go check it out
this Obama gate scandal is the biggest
one of our lifetimes and it's not
getting any play because the media are
corrupt and in bed with the officials
involved and because it's a little bit
complicated so I'm going to try to
simplify it in just like one or two
minutes more than a dozen Obama
administration officials high-ranking
Obama administration officials signed
off on the unmasking of Michael Flynn
Michael Flynn was the incoming national
security advisor for Trump this happened
during the presidential transition
period so after Trump had won the
election before he's inaugurated one of
the officials who signed off on the
unmasking of Michael Flynn was Joe Biden
the current Democratic frontrunner I
guess I don't know where he is I'm not
convinced he is still with us but he is
theoretically going to be the Democratic
nominee in November other senior Obama
officials include UN Ambassador Samantha
power CIA director John Brennan and the
White House chief of staff Denis
McDonough
what is unmasking we know what masking
is we do a lot of that these days what
is unmasking unmasking refers to the
ability of the government to spy on
foreigners
in certain cases particularly if the
foreigners foreign governments foreign
people have some relationship to
terrorism that's in particular sometimes
when you're spying on these foreigners
you pick up conversations with American
citizens those conversations are then
masked because the government doesn't
have this carte blanche right to just
spy on American citizens and then make
that available to other people in the
government so you'll see who the foreign
official is but they will mask who the
American official is sometimes
intelligence officials can request that
the NSA no such agency National Security
Agency unmask those American citizens
for security purposes so reveal who the
American citizens are who are talking to
the foreign officials that does not
appear to be what happened here it
wasn't some Intel officials for a
legitimate investigation who were doing
this unmasking actually what happened
here is that politicians very prominent
politicians requested this this is very
strange it's very odd for requests for
unmasking to come from politicians
particularly politicians this high up
very strange very rare for requests like
this to come in a period of presidential
transition meaning from the outgoing
administration into the incoming
administration frankly seems
unprecedented think of the effect that
this decision had that Joe Biden signed
off on to unmask Mike Flynn
had the effect of allowing the previous
administration to nullify the incoming
National Security Director just took him
out or national security adviser rather
forced the incoming Attorney General to
recuse himself so Trump didn't he didn't
get an NSA right away he didn't get an
attorney general for much of his
administration or his first term first
term please hostile bureaucrats were
then allowed to undermine the
administration from within
during the Trump administration
completely kneecapped the administration
in the first three years and covered up
the truth covered up the truth for what
are we at now three and a half years
it's just beginning to come out
almost a full presidential term what the
Obama people were hoping would be the
full Trump presidential term this all
goes back to a January 5th meeting where
and we know about this meeting because
former Obama National Security Advisor
Susan Rice wrote an unusual email to
herself to take notes about this meeting
that she attended with Deputy Attorney
General Sally Yates FBI director Jim
Comey and VP Joe Biden she sent this
email to herself why maybe to have some
notes why maybe to exonerate herself if
this effort came out the the note said
President Obama said he wants to be sure
that as we engage with the incoming team
were mindful to ascertain if there is
any reason that we cannot share
information fully as it relates to
Russia see the implication here you need
what it would seem that that meeting is
suggesting is that the outgoing
administration needs to be able to frame
the incoming administration in such a
way that they can keep power for
themselves hold over power for
themselves keep it away from the Trump
administration why did this happen why
did this happen if I were a gambling man
here's my theory I think a pretty
straightforward theory the Obama
administration spied on the Trump
campaign we know that they spied on the
Trump campaign using BS Intel cooked up
by Democrats ironically colluding with
the Russians through the steal dossier
we know that for a fact when Trump
unexpectedly won he wasn't supposed to
win remember 99% chance Hillary wins the
Obama administration knew that they had
to cover their tracks because what they
did was so egregious so they had to keep
the bogus Russia investigations going
which they did by entrapping inside
lining Flinn and forcing sessions to
recuse himself that bought them almost
entire an entire presidential
administration of the Russia hoax
investigations and distractions and they
almost got away with it they got so
close but they didn't they didn't get
away with it we now see it coming out
there is criminal investigation being
conducted by John Durham we'll see what
happens next I have two big takeaways
one sort of gives us
some confidence for the Trump
administration and one is a little bit
sadder we'll get to that in a second
first to get to thank our friends over
first leaf you know I love all of our
sponsors but I really love first leaf
because I really like wine and I really
like good wine and I don't like paying
good wine prices picture this you're at
home you're finishing a glass of wine
just as you're about to pour another it
happens the realization that you're out
the bottles are gone they call that no
vino phobia the fear of running out of
wine that's the official expert
scientific technical term thanks to
first leaf I get personalized boxes of
wine shipped right to my door I've had
other wine clubs before they don't even
come close to first leaf they don't even
come close I pay for first leaf net they
gave me a freebie for a month or two I
now pay and I get the best package I can
they know they not only know but then
they learn even more your taste in wine
they send you really cool stuff really
high excellent excellent quality listen
I've had a bottle of wine or two in my
life this this place is theirs there's
no pier to it you've got to try it out
especially now when it's harder to go to
the store first leaf has a hundred
percent satisfaction guarantee so if you
receive a bottle you're not in to first
leaf we'll cover the cost sign up today
get six bottles of wine for only twenty
nine ninety five plus free shipping very
low price try that try first leaf calm
slash Knowles six bottles of wine for
only twenty nine ninety five at try
first leaf calm slash Knowles canna wles
my two takeaways here this is the
biggest political scandal of our
lifetimes by far this is much much worse
than Watergate
you always hear political pundits and
analysts and commentators they say this
is worse than Watergate about whatever
scandal it is in the Obama
administration you could talk about the
IRS targeting scandal you could talk
about fast and furious you could talk
about any number of things in the Trump
administration I don't know you could
talk about how he sent some mean tweets
sometimes they say it's worse than
Watergate I don't use that phrase I
don't think I've ever used that phrase
to refer to a political scandal yet I am
using it to refer to this one this is
truly worse than Watergate goes up much
higher very likely touches the present
himself we need to know what Barack
Obama knew and when he knew it
we need to subpoena these people find
out what the the logic was for unmasking
Michael Flint and find out why the vice
president of the United States signed
off on this why went so high got so
political eight days before he left
office got to find out what that January
fifth meeting was all about that Susan
Rice sent that email to herself about
got to find out a whole lot of stuff
because it stinks to high heaven and I
can't imagine any evidence that would
exculpate these guys that's the one
takeaway the other takeaway is they're
probably gonna get away with them
they're probably gonna get away with it
that's just a political reality why
wouldn't they it's Obama's old news he
did get away with it right he finished
his administration Joe Biden is the
Democratic nominee right now so the
trial of these people is going to be
held in the court of public opinion at
the ballot box perhaps as it should be
no one's gonna cover it it's too
complicated for people to really digest
you know at least in Watergate Watergate
was was not as complicated there's just
kind of a bungled burglary that the
president
I guess covered up I mean it's like
nothing compared to this but it was a
little more straightforward and
obviously at a news media they're
pushing it all the time and you had
Republicans who folded this it's it's
it's more complicated the only place
that people are gonna be able to weigh
in is at the ballot box okay speaking of
which Joe Biden just had a fairly
unfortunate interview with Vanity Fair
Vanity Fair is not a right wing
publication but the Vanity Fair
contributor Peter Hamby confronted Joe
Biden on video about all of the mean
things that people call him on the
Internet is really a delightful
interview Biden didn't have a great
response the Shorenstein Center up at
Harvard did a study of all of the anti
Biden memes out there on the Internet
and according to them the top three
slogans they're seeing this is from the
left and the right are dementia Joe
sleepy Joe creepy Joe Barack Obama
reportedly said last week that his
daughters have been showing him anti
biting tic TOCs you can't make us vote
for Joe bide and you can't make that's
vote for Joe Biden basically there's an
discourse on the internet right now
that's painting you is creepy and old
and out of touch and kind of lame how do
you fight back against that look Trump
is a master at laying nicknames on
people but the vast majority of voters
out there that have voted including
young people are not getting all the
news from the internet and but I'm
trying to compete there we're getting
started late coming a comparative sense
the vast majority of people including
young people are not getting their news
from the internet I'm not out of touch
you know who is that a touch that really
small group of people who use this
newfangled thing called the Internet nah
me me look I'm in touch they call me in
touch Joe alright I come home every
night I put on the phonograph and I
listen to the latest recordings of the
news I think he actually used the phrase
phonograph during a debate do you
remember that he said he was making some
what was then immediately perceived as a
racially insensitive comment Joe Biden
is kind of known for those about how it
was like black families need to play put
the record player on for their kids to
raid initially he said you know put on
the the music the CD the the phonograph
the record player it was it got worse
and worse and worse and I guess he's
doing it again that's Joe Biden please
please don't make them vote for Joe
Biden there they're rattled okay you
know Joe Biden is very good at keeping
his composure a lot of the time but it
isn't going well I think Democrats are
scared about this because nobody wants
to vote for Joe Biden you're now in the
worst economic crisis since the Great
Depression possibly depending on how the
next few weeks play out and yet still
Donald Trump looks like he's gonna be
Joe Biden because Joe Biden is a walking
cadaver he's not a real candidate he was
always kind of a doof you know from the
80s and then he ran again in the 2000s
now he's running again now no one ever
really liked him it's never a great
candidate but he can't even beat Trump
during this particular instance and you
have Obama game hanging over everybody
including implicating the nominee just
to show you I mean the good thing about
this being weighed in at the ballot
is the Republicans can make an issue out
of this if they can get their messaging
right
we know that the Democrats won't get
their messaging right cuz Joe Biden
can't form a coherent sentence and the
DNC spokesman has no answer on this she
went on Fox News I can't pronounce her
name because it's got too many
consonants in a row but her last name is
Hinojosa
and this spokesman DNC communications
director goes on Fox News is asked about
Obama gait and sputters in in a way I
can't even I can't even listen to the
whole clip and something like I'm asking
if something that you are just looking
to see more intelligent it is nothing
that is scandalous in any way but
frankly this is going to backfire on
Republicans because it just showed how
serious Flynn was and his conversations
with the Russians so Republicans can try
to use this to play political football
this is going to backfire is that a
crime to talk to other countries there
in that period well whenever you are are
trying to interfere in an election or in
any way and try to go against the United
States I think that you know that is
something that is and so I think that
right now is they're printing this
Justice Department politicize issues in
order to help Donald Trump the answer
there was a suggestion that there was
collusion
there's been no proof of that where's
yours you continue to see this Justice
Department and specifically you know
Bill Barr trying to cover up for the
president generally oh that's so
embarrassing you know I'm really glad
that she doesn't have an answer to this
because it shows how weak the Democrats
cases but it's someone you know I've
done a lot of TV news hits that I can't
even imagine how that must have felt in
the moment where she just she's sitting
there she's on national television she's
on the biggest cable news network and
she don't have an answer what on earth
is the answer this gives us some
strategy going into November which is we
got to turn up the light we got to turn
up the heat sunlight is a great dish
infect him that's true when it comes to
viruses it's true when it comes to
political scandals we will get to a
little bit more and then the mailbag but
first I've got to thank you gotta thank
you and take a moment to tell you about
Daily wires newest most exclusive
membership to your all-access the all
access membership tier is our premier
level of membership all access members
get to participate in all access lives
eats cheat night at 8:00 p.m. Eastern
5:00 p.m. Pacific now I don't even call
it a show because it's you're just
hanging out and these days the only way
you can hang out with anybody is online
so come hang out with us it's a lot of
fun you also get three more hours three
total hours of the bench Bureau show
exclusive q and A's you get of course
the Leptis news tumbler you need that
head on over to daily wire calm slash
subscribe to join daily wires all-access
Club with the new membership or an
upgrade get 10% off with coupon code
Knowles that is daily wire calm /
subscribe coupon code Knowles we'll see
you there be right back with some more
news in the mailbag
just a little piece of news I have to
get to before we get into the mailbag
out of California California's 25th
congressional district just flipped
Republican for the first time since 1998
no Republican since 1998 has flipped any
district in California and Mike Garcia
who I believe is a Navy pilot and he's
really really good candidate
he just won that seat over Democrat
Christie Smith by 12 points that seat
was forfeited by Democrat Katie hill
best known for having a throuple with
her husband and a staffer and kind of
burning the staffer I think leaving the
husband anyway it's a mess it's a mess
those scandals don't really don't really
help you keep your congressional seat so
that's good news
you know this is say this fairly
moderate district is that going to tell
us something about November obviously
not every congressional district has a
throuple having incumbent but might tell
us something about November might tell
us something about pushback against the
Democrats overreach we're seeing that in
Wisconsin 4-3 decision at the Wisconsin
Supreme Court struck down governor Tony
eavers stay-at-home order in Wisconsin
meaning Wisconsin is reopening as it
should this is some good news even
amidst all these crazy political
scandals and a bunch of dumb orders that
we're all going to ignore from mayor's
like Eric Garcetti there is a little bit
of good news all right let's get into
the mailbag from Chasse chasity
or chastity dear noble Knowles I'm a
registered nurse in Oklahoma I listen to
your show faithfully and was basically
silenced among my peers for my beliefs
on the cove in nineteen crisis until
this week last week was Nurses Week we
were showered with lunches and gifts
only to be emailed by our CEO that they
would be making drastic cuts cutting
leadership salaries by 26 percent for a
loving thousands of frontline employees
and stopping 401k contributions they
said those who still had jobs would have
to be thankful for that and step up they
will freeze any hiring if they run out
of pto you'll need to pay your portion
of health benefits or those benefits
will be terminated well we have no
income this shutdown is not only
jobs so many Americans but also the
healthcare frontline workers are paying
the same price part of my many reasons
for becoming a nurse was job security
I'm now faced with the uncertainty of
losing my job I have many nursing
friends across the u.s. who are facing
similar fates from their hospitals my
question is why is this not the biggest
news story if this isn't the biggest
indicator that scientists got it wrong
I'm not sure what else could be very
sorry to hear that you're going through
all of that and I'm not terribly
surprised from the beginning there's
been a lot of demagoguery on this from
the lab coats and from more more than
that from the politicians who amplify
the lab coats and the commentators who
do that as well and they've set up a lot
of false dichotomies they've said that
either we can save people's lives or
open the economy but we can't do both
and if you open the economy you're gonna
kill people actually there's no evidence
the lockdowns have saved a single life
and there is plenty of evidence that the
lock dents have killed people so they
got that one dead wrong another one they
have is either you can support the
lockdowns and support health care
workers or oppose the lockdowns and
oppose health care workers this is a
line that's become popular on the left
it's health care worker it's a alleged
health care worker slogan we're here for
you so stay home for us and so it's good
for the health care workers if you stay
home but that's not true that's not true
many if not most health care workers in
the US are at serious risk of losing
their jobs if we don't reopen the
economy because the influx from
coronavirus hasn't been anywhere near as
dramatic as people said it would
right the Javits Center emergency
hospital in New York was basically empty
that hospital ship in New York was
basically empty same thing in California
we just haven't seen that overwhelming
of the health care system meanwhile
every other medical procedure is not
being conducted so you're actually when
you stay home you're actually hurting
the health care workers in in pretty
significant ways so I'm sorry to hear
you're going through that I'm sorry to
hear that our politicians are such
dummies and I'm sorry to hear that the
American people are gonna give up their
faculties of reason and self-government
for a bunch of tube it would be experts
in lab coats it's just very very
unfortunate situation all around does
appear the tide has turned a little bit
we should incur
and we should ignore all the stupid
orders arbitrary power grabs that are
being foisted on us from Aiden dear mr.
Knowles as you have mentioned on
previous episodes loneliness in the u.s.
has been on the rise especially among
Millennials what would you recommend
someone who is feeling lonely do to
overcome this issue and how could they
improve their human relations when
encountering new individuals loneliness
is the it is affecting everybody well
certainly right now in the quarantine
but it effects people virtually
everybody in modern liberal secular
society it isolates even the the person
you would say is the greatest social
butterfly you know he's very good at
talking to people or whatever very often
you'll see that people in terms of their
you know serious relationships whether
boyfriend/girlfriend marriage you know
husband wife or deep friendships not
just the kind of you know amicable get
along drinking buddy kind of stuff but
really deep friendship grounded in in
real substance those don't exist very
much and if you have any of those you're
very fortunate but for for it may be
most people that that isn't really going
away so what what do I recommend you do
first thing is go to church it has a
very practical effect you'll be around a
lot of people and you'll talk to people
and most of them recognize that humans
are social and we actually need to
engage with one another but also it will
it'll just focus your view of the world
because one one temptation when you're
feeling lonely is to try to get
something for yourself you know to get a
hookup or a girlfriend do you know or is
it but for you or a friend to hang out
with for you and that's obviously not
how human relationships work you you get
the most out of it when you give the
most of yourself away so first one
always good advice go to church beyond
that you have to prioritize real person
interaction digital is not enough it's a
good start it's nice that we have that
option especially in quarantine but it's
not sufficient we are incarnation abhi
have bodies we got flesh and meat that's
part of who we are we live in time we
live in space it's not
enough simply to abstract that to text
messages or emails or even Skype
FaceTime zoom it isn't enough you got to
be in person with somebody to to really
develop that relationship you got to you
got to visit people you got to you got
to really make the effort to do that
those are two things I would do right
away they're pretty simple to do right
when the country whenever it does open
back up you can always go to a coffee
shop always go to a bar always go to
some interest group you can you can be
around people even if they're not
friends of yours even if you don't know
them very well
and certainly you can always go to
church that would be my first place to
start and you know open yourselves up to
talking to people recognize that the
whole world isn't about you and then
ironically your own life your own
self-interest will get a lot better from
Travis hello Michael
what are some private sector career
paths available for somebody deeply
interested in politics
I am studying political science in
college and don't want to run for office
and yet would love to make a career
dealing with political issues many
thanks now you're gonna run into a
problem which is that politics is by
definition public so it's not private
now the distinction between public and
private is a little blurry sometimes but
politics by definition is a public thing
now probably what you're saying is you
don't want to work with a government
which just makes perfect sense and you
know unfortunately for you a lot of
politics does occur at the governmental
level but some of it does not so one
clear example in the private sector
would be working in political media so
that could involve you writing columns
you know write or being a straight
political reporter or being a professor
you know professors if you're working a
private university or in the private
sector or it could mean you work at some
political nonprofit or it could mean you
work at some political think-tank but
there isn't too much political business
I guess you know there aren't political
factories churning out politics beyond
what I've just described because
politics is is public politics is and it
does relate most directly
to the government so I wouldn't limit
yourself to saying I don't want to have
anything to do with the government I
don't want to have anything to do with
with the public because you know that's
just not how politics works and politics
also it's not a not a straight career
path you're gonna have a lot of
different jobs in politics you know I
mean I started my first political job
was when I was 18 18 or 19 and you know
you hop on this campaign in that
campaign this political action committee
this you're writing for this person
you're talking to this person you've got
this show I mean it's just it's a really
fun wild career path but you can't be
too choosy about it from Justin Michael
is it more American to buy a Ford made
in Mexico or a Toyota made in America I
love the show wow what a good question I
would have to say it's more American to
buy the Toyota made in America really
what this question is doing is asking
you to choose between something that
really looks like what you want and
something that really is more like what
you want and it's also asking you to
choose between profits for owners and
workers and employment and you know
company loyalty
now those those things are not always at
odds but when they are at odds I kind of
go more for the America working having
our own manufacturing having some whale
tea to this country and being more of
the thing rather than merely looking at
the thing you know I was I was an actor
earlier in my in my 20s in my wayward
youth and some I sometimes joke about
that'ss I used to be an actor now I'm
the real thing I think it's better to be
more in the camp of reality from Michael
hello Michael of the camp of Knowles by
was weird that those two words it's
quite a coincidence maybe it's
Providence I don't know most austere
religious podcaster my question is about
the teaching of Jesus Christ as a
historical figure as well as a biblical
one why is Jesus not mentioned in the
history books that are taught in a
school we have records that predate
Jesus so might it be a way of keeping
God out of schools under the auspices of
the separation of church and state or
something more insidious thanks for all
you do it's
the fact that we even discussed this as
a distinction shows you how rotten the
problem of an atheist culture has gotten
that we say well there's the biblical
Jesus and the historical Jesus there's
of course when I was in college called
the historical Jesus as though those
were different people as though the
Bible is that's not true that's
ridiculous there's a bunch of fairy
tales there are the most reliable
documents we have of the era but ya know
sure it's just that's a fairy tale
the real historical Jesus disproves
Christianity entirely that's that's the
kind of narrative they want to tell you
based on very little evidence the
Gospels are historically very reliable
right great you know unlike other
religions Christianity is not founded
exactly in poetry or philosophy it's
founded on journalism the Gospels are
journalists accounts of the life of
Christ and and what happened afterward
with the Apostles you know and the rest
of the New Testament the letters write
those they're like those could be
newspaper columns this you know the
epistles so I would I would look there
first why is Jesus not mentioned in in
the history books in history classes
these days at other times in history he
was taught but it shows you not only how
corrupt our own time has become but a
little bit of what Christ was telling us
about which is that the world is going
to hate him in the world is going to
hate you
because of him I mean regardless of what
you think about the divinity of Jesus
surely he is the most important person
that ever walked the earth he changed
everything when you talk about how
history is taught the way that we date
things is about him right we have before
Christ and anno anno domini the year of
our Lord ad right refers to the year of
Christ now they try to change that they
keep the exact same scale but they now
call it before the Common Era and after
the Common Era they're actively trying
to write Jesus out of history same thing
with the Saints the Saints are the
greatest people that ever lived and yet
were never taught about them no weird
you know a secular culture would look at
that and say see it's evidence that they
don't really matter but someone with any
reason or wisdom would look at that and
say gosh that's evidence that it's all
true alright before we go let's get to
one quick one from Paul and Elizabeth
dear Michael could you give us some
concise pro-trump talking points we have
some conservative Christian friends who
are reluctant to enthusiastically
support President Trump because of his
behavior or at least the media's
portrayal of his behavior can we shine a
light on his accomplishments all the
best yes first of all if you're worried
about Trump's behavior don't forget
anything the Trump is being accused of
Joe Biden is accused of two trump's
accused of lying joe biden as she had to
drop out of the presidential race in
1988 because of he he is a proven liar
he's lied about virtually everything
you're worried about the sexual
allegations Donald Trump's a little bit
of a playboy and he pays off porn stars
apparently Joe Biden is being accused
with some credibility of sexual assault
that one's off the table too Donald
Trump uses colorful language Joe Biden
uses colorful language let's not forget
when that Obama health care bill passed
we said this is a big effing deal on
microphone before the International
Press so I would take that off the table
then what is Trump accomplished most
importantly the judges has given us all
of these judges who will craft for for a
generation or more our legal system the
way we interpret laws very possibly
prevent the redefinition of biological
sex very possibly save lots of babies
through the gradual at least we hope
abolition of this fictitious right to
abortion in the Constitution very
important stuff if your conservative
Christian as you say your friends are
you want that you can't vote for a
pro-abortion politician you can't vote
for someone who wants to radically
redefine the very nature of existence
Kenpo for socialists that's just the
judges he's also wrecked to credibility
of the media he's preserved relative
peace abroad he treats our allies like
our allies and our enemies like our
enemies he does what he says he's going
to do he's let people keep more of their
own money as he promised that he would
the economy was doing very well before
China sniped us out with this Wuhan
and it's a it's it's just been very good
I mean I guess I can't think of real
downsides to the administration I can
pick a little bill or two here I didn't
like that jailbreak bill that he passed
you know I think it was what about a
year ago but other than that who cares
it's okay it's pretty good
administration I would ask them what
their objections are because I think
pretty simple answers to the objections
all right one last one before we go from
Nick dear master of the absence of the
written language my question is what is
more likely for you to vote for Joe
Biden in November or for me to spot ben
shapiro ad for a jog eating bacon
listening to his ipod on a Saturday
afternoon thanks in order for Ben to eat
bacon on a Saturday afternoon the only
way that that would happen I think is
the second coming of Jesus Christ
proving definitively that Christianity
is true right in the minds of everybody
and there is no way for me to vote for
Joe Biden in November is certainly much
more likely that the Second Coming will
happen and the end times and the
Christianity is true obviously have
stakes a lot of my life on that
so clearly clearly the latter all right
that's our Sean Michael knowles is the
Michael Nolt show CI Monday
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Ben Davies and directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy borin
supervising producers Mathis Glover and
Robert Stirling technical producer
Austin Stephens assistant director pavel
Woodhouse key editor and associate
producer danny D'Amico audio mixer robin
fenders hair and makeup
Nika Geneva production assistant Ryan
love the Michael Noel's show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
20
you know the Matt Walsh oh it's not just
another show about about politics I
think there are enough of those already
out there we talk about culture because
culture drives politics and it drives
everything else so my main focus is our
life family faith those are fundamental
and that's what this show is about I
hope you'll give it a listen